i know you guys spoke to jerry about
national treasure three a while back
believe me i bring it up with him every
single time i talk to him
uh i i tried my damnedest to get
national treasure three up i i love
those movies i worked on those from
from sort of inception yeah believe me i
was gonna bring this up i have to ask
you with national treasure
so to me i i think one and please
correct me if i'm wrong on this but
my gut feeling is that one of the
reasons national treasure
three didn't go is that when the first
one was made
hollywood was a completely different
beast where there was a lot more first
dollar gross
a lot more producers getting money like
the economic system
that's sure that that is for sure
producers do not make what they used to
right so what i'm saying what i'm saying
though with national treasure is
you know back then when nick cage did it
he was getting a lot more money a lot
more there was a lot more
money being pulled in terms of like say
the movie made 100 million dollars maybe
30 million was going to people before
the studio saw anything i'm just
guessing at this right
so my question is is one of the reasons
national treasure 3 never got
made is because it was almost too
expensive to make the movie
because of old production deals no
although that's a
that is a concern anytime you do a
sequel particularly sequel that has
historical first dollar grows out um
there's always a way to work around
those deals it never got to that um on
national treasure 3 when i was around
i i think that part of what happened and
this is a more
sort of uh uh insider nuance take on it
to be honest
um what i felt happen is even though the
movies themselves were extremely
successful and had
really a really strong fan base it's
it's it's a movie that gets brought up
all the time
particularly the first one unfortunately
the company was never
able to capitalize on it as a franchise
it really operated in the market more as
a movie with a sequel
and national treasure 3 would have been
another sequel
they never found a way to integrate it
into the parks it never caught on
as driving even though there were a lot
of consumer products books and things
like that
it never really caught on as as an
independent franchise and i think that
makes the numbers look
different it makes the it makes it
harder to get
a company like disney to focus resources
on something
when they can go make toy story or go
buy a
cruise ship um and if
if the company itself had been really
excited about moving forward with it and
thought that they could
could blow it out um we would have found
a way to make the deals
yeah so basically you're saying if
national people had bought national
treasure
action figures national treasure three
uh i think it's more if we had i think
today
there is something there's some really
interesting stuff that you could have
moved national treasure out right so
i'll give you an example of like why i
love that
movie not just from a from an
entertainment standpoint
but we shot at the national archives
which was not easy to pull off the
production team
tore their hair out trying to get the
approvals through the federal government
and all of that stuff
then the year after the movie came out
attendance at the national archives went
up 400 percent
and it stayed high and it has continued
to stay at an elevated level since that
movie came out
and i loved that the number of
friends of mine the number of family
members who came and said you know what
my kid won't stop talking about american
history
and he's reading all these books and now
i've got to read these books so that i
don't look stupid in front of my kid
i thought that was like one of the
greatest things that ever happened and
the ben gates character
the reason i love the ben gates
character is because his super powers
that he
cares and that he's smart and
it's not he's not the strongest guy he's
not pulling out a gun
he's not kicking somebody's ass he's
using his
intelligence and his sort of lack of
cynicism to win the day
and and i love that about him and i
think that's um
it's harder to do but i thought it paid
off so
i really think that nowadays um
with the technology with the smartphones
all that there's a way to take that
fun and move it out into the digital
space
and to whether it's location-based
gameplay or or things like pokemon go or
whatever
that you could have done to really make
it a bigger
uh cultural uh
to have it have a bigger cultural impact
than it did that said
i know jerry keeps working on stuff and
i know that there's a lot of interest in
a series
and in a another feature and i think
it's right to sort of reinvent
again i've interviewed him what every
time i've interviewed him for like 10
years that's my main question
but he did give me you know what's
interesting about jerry is that he never
gives me a scoop
he he's so good on his talking
and when i was talking to him last time
he actually dropped how they were
developing it for disney plus
as a national treasure series and as he
said it i'm like
i actually think no one knows this but i
didn't want to say anything
enough you know after i'm like oh wow he
actually gave me a really good story
thank you yeah make it up yeah i mean
he's been doing the he's been doing
press for a long time
i couldn't believe it it was the first
time in you know all my years of talking
to him that i got something that was
you know an actual breakout story like
that